now that we're getting into tax filing
season and we have the new withholding
tables from the Trump Republican tax
plan enacted and sort of factored in I
guess we would say to people's paychecks
there's a couple different tax related
issues I want to talk about with you I
recently met with our accountant to
finalize the David Pakman show taxes and
he said in no uncertain terms David I
know you're against the tax overhaul
politically but it's very good for your
business because of the changes that it
makes to pass through income as well as
a few other changes and I recognize that
and we were told it's going to be good
not just for businesses but also for
most people but we have a new Politico
morning consult poll out now which finds
that more than half of all working
voters haven't seen an increase in their
paychecks and here at the David Pakman
show we have everybody here is getting a
little bit more money in their checks
every couple of weeks but anecdotal
evidence is anecdotal and only 37% of
employed voters have seen their pay
increase based on the new withholding
tables and what's interesting is that
Republicans were way more likely to
report higher paychecks than Democrats
meaning someone is lying and it's
probably both Republicans and some
Democrats lying about the impact of the
tax overhaul on their paychecks but
regardless we know for sure who is
getting a major tax windfall even though
they already paid zero federal taxes in
2017 and that is a huge corporation
called Amazon because of a strategy that
Amazon has been employing for a long
time Amazon reported about five and a
half billion dollars in profits last
year and paid zero federal taxes now you
might be wondering how is that possible
and the reason is that it's a
combination of tax credits and tax
breaks for executives stock options
which zeroed out their federal taxes for
last year and
over the last five years Amazon paid an
effective federal income tax rate of
just eleven point four percent but none
of that is the news right that that all
predates the Trump tax bill the news is
that because of the tax overhaul Amazon
is going to get a one-time seven hundred
and eighty nine million dollar tax break
this isn't the David Pakman show is not
an accounting show but basically Amazon
had deferred some tax liability from
previous years and now they can get a
40% discount on that tax liability from
thirty five percent to twenty one
percent which will work out to saving
them about seven hundred eighty nine
million dollars nice little spring bonus
right close to a billion extra dollars
in your pocket that you don't have to
pay out so yeah not nearly everyone is
seeing more money in their paychecks but
we are seeing hundreds of millions of
dollars in tax breaks for major
companies and then remember all those
Republicans that said look this company
is giving raises because of the tax cuts
and that company is going to give a
bonus because of the tax cuts it is all
a ruse what do I mean it's a ruse well
some of the companies that announced
bonuses also laid off a ton of employees
and AT&T is an example of that other
companies that announce bonuses are
after all giving one-time bonuses when
they're going to get years and years and
years of tax benefits so it's mostly PR
and most of the money that they save is
going to go to executives and
shareholders as we predicted and as we
knew would happen and then some of the
companies I've gotten emails from people
who said David my company is foregoing
raises this year because they're saying
hey you're already getting a little more
money in your paycheck because of the
changes to the tax code so we're not
going to give a raise because your raise
was basically the new tax plan and
remember the personal tax cuts are set
to expire after yes 2025 whereas the
corporate tax cuts are gonna keep in
place that's right so this is a big hand
out to corporations it's amazing scraps
to keep them you know satisfied but I'm
not an ally and the bigger picture is
that when you hear about a few dozen
companies
that are giving bonuses or raises or
whatever every corporation got the same
tax cuts and we've heard that a few
dozen are giving raises or bonuses this
is zero point zero zero I don't know how
many zeros zero one percent of all
companies and this is where people get
tricked right a lot of economics is BS
true sort of rational neoclassical
economics econometrics there's a lot of
crap in the field of economics but the
part that's not crap is that it tells us
big picture what happens when a tax cut
disproportionately goes to the rich in
corporations and what happens is that it
lines the pockets of people that don't
need the money
it doesn't stimulate the economy in a
meaningful way and to the extent that we
care about the deficit and different
people care about the deficit
differently some of it depends on the
party of the person in the white house
it increases the deficit and therefore
the debt so the people who saw a little
extra money
I hate to tell you Pat you're probably
getting screwed anyway because number
one it's temporary
number two the gas tax might have to go
up well actually you have no car so I
guess that that one doesn't really
affect you health care costs are likely
going to keep going up actually you're
young enough to be on your parents
health insurance so that one doesn't
affect you either
so I guess Pat's going to be okay but a
lot of people who are seeing a little
bit of extra money in their paychecks
are going to get screwed elsewhere and
meanwhile the corporate tax cuts are
permanent is this the change people
wanted when they voted for Donald Trump
or is it more bamboozling from Donald
Trump and from supply-side economics you
tell me but that's the early some of the
early results of this massive overhaul
that we've seen to our tax code the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad